oui on a qu'à une première invitée
politique bonjour soit avec veulent
toujours merci beaucoup d'être avec vous
allez faire votre entrée à l'assemblée
nationale c'est une situation vous avez
été lire avec plus de 57 % des voix en
seine-et-marne et vous siégerait dans le
groupe horizon c'est le parti d'edouard
philippe on le voit ensemble la
coalition de la majorité présidentielle
est loin très loin de la majorité
absolue c'est une claque
c'est effectivement
celui des fêtes parce que l'objectif
effectivement c'est d'avoir des
institutions stables et sans reproduire
ce qui a été le quinquennat précédent
peut être effectivement on a vu les
limites d'un groupe qui était trop
puissant mais néanmoins c'était d'avoir
une majorité vous éclaire une majorité
absolue avec les différentes composantes
qui était celle de la majorité
présidentielle aujourd'hui on en est
loin donc c'est effectivement un autre
mode de gouvernance qui doit se mettre
en place très différent de ce qu'on
connaît classiquement la vème république
et encore plus du quinquennat qui vient
de se passer parce que effectivement
haut var vaire sans doute incontrable de
gouvernement qui doit associer
qui doit associer des personnalités ou
des groupes effectivement différent donc
les choses se doit se décider dans les
prochains jours sous quelle rond dans
les prochains jours mais ça va être
effectivement une autre mode de gestion
notre mode de gestion et de la majorité
ils vont quand même 45 sièges majorité
absolue bien vu est ce que cette
assemblée n'est pas un gouvernable
écoutez on va pas commencer à dire
qu'elle est ingouvernable avant même que
ce soit réuni que les discussions aient
commencé ce qui est très clair c'est que
tout va dépendre de la ligne politique
qui va être retenu de là où seront mis
les curseurs et et de la volonté de
celui qui finalement était le jaune est
à l'origine de cette majorité un là qui
est quand même malgré tout posé au
milieu d'eux delà de l'assemblée
emmanuel macron d'organiser
effectivement la discussion avec
d'autres composantes peut-être demain de
ce qui sera une future majorité mais qui
alors ils avaient tort
on va travailler pour avoir une majorité
d'actions avec qui vous allez travailler
christian jacob à fermer la portière
pour les christian jacob et christian
jacob quitte la prieure duel de l'air
dans quelques semaines un changement de
ligne avec le départ du lean qui emmène
les l'air à ce retrait cir d'élections
d'élection aux occupations éclair suivi
globalement hormis jean françois copé
sur cette île a droit déjà des mères qui
disent il faut peut-être
renouveler le la discussion avec eux
avec emmanuel macron est-ce qu'il faut
refaire un quinquennat d'opposition pour
l'opposition comme ce qui est un fait
l'air et qui l'a conduit de passer de
100 députés à
jeu ses premiers sont ce matin mais ça
sentait la santé 1 voilà ils étaient 200
il ya quelques années donc
certains veulent un nombre aussi avec
cette logique de d'opposition pour
l'opposition certains j'ai bien entendu
d'un groupe sont aussi tenant de cette
ligne là je pense à monsieur ciotti bon
maintenant je ne sais je sais j'ai
quitté l'ère il ya maintenant plus de
sept ans dont je suis plus très bien où
en sont les équilibres internes mais
est-ce que vous avez aux discussions
avec moi qui venait de la droite est ce
que vous allez ouvrir discussions avec
les
dix donc de toutes façons horizon peut
jouer un rôle aussi de deux passerelles
enfin je veux dire et c'est logique et
normal de passerelles parce que on le
sait pour accueillir de nouveaux députés
pourquoi pas la blonde il bouge mais on
le savait avant l'élection on l'a bien
vu par la campagne présidentielle de
valérie pécresse il ya énormément d'élus
locaux énormément peut-être aussi de ses
futurs députés de ces nouveaux députés
aujourd'hui et l'air dans les nouvelles
générations qui n'ont pas du tout la
même approche dogmatique fermé vis-à-vis
des manuels macron que celle qui est à
la tête de l'air depuis quelques années
donc oui il ya sans doute effective donc
vous misez sur une implosion dlr pas une
implosion galère mais un je pense qu'on
peut aussi inventé un parement des
choses qui soit négocié discuté à partir
d'un jardin d'un contrat de gouttes
d'eau gouvernement qui soit clairement
posé c'est pas notre culture et c'est
pas la culture française on le voit plus
faire dans des pays proches
et pense à l'allemagne mais tant
d'autres aussi peut-être que
effectivement la france dans cette
configuration institutionnelle la doua
inventé une nouvelle manière de je le
redis de gouverner et sur la base d'une
coalition et faute d'accord de
gouvernement il va falloir négocier des
majorités au cas par cas sur chaque
texte est ce que vous sollicitez dans ce
cas là tous les suffrages à l'assemblée
y compris ceux du rassemblement national
par exemple je pense qu'on n'en est pas
là enfin il ya clairement prendre à la
fin d'abord je quand même rappeler une
chose c'est que la majorité
présidentielle
même si elle n'est pas une majorité
absolue elle a fait campagne derrière
emmanuel macron il ya de ce point de vue
là une cohérence qui est forte si on
regarde ce qu'on a autour de monsieur
mélenchon sait pas car on a un
agglomérat de 2,2 de coalition qui avait
des codes et des équipes qui n'ont pas
fait campagne derrière le même candidat
ça veut dire vous misez par exemple sur
quelques voix du côté du ps ce n'est pas
de la france insoumise nommé chacun va
reprendre sa liberté du côté dessus
chacun va reprendre sa liberté parce
qu'il y avait une bannière commune
derrière des candidats qui avaient fait
des campagnes présidentielles aux
tonalités très différentes entre les
communistes et écologistes les
socialistes et les mélenchonistes donc
chacun va reprendre et monsieur
mélenchon n'est par la tête d'un groupe
nuxe de 230 parlementaire il est à la
tête d'un groupe dont on dit qu'il sera
83,83 début c'est à dire loin d'être le
rôle principal dans l'opposition de se
recaler aussi de ce point de vue là il
ya peut-être du côté des socialistes des
écologistes des gens de bonne volonté
qui on regarde différents et moins
dogmatique sur l'action du président un
public on était à matignon il ya
quelques minutes qu'elisabeth borne est
la première ministre adéquat vu les
résultats et vu la manière dont ces
lasers gérer la jav alors il est
question c'est tout je ne veux pas
rentrer dans les questions à notre
prochaine plus adroits politique c'est
tout tout dépend de la ligne politique
c'est la ligne politique qui génère des
terminera finalement
ce qui déterminera la les coalitions
dont je parle c'est pas la personnalité
ou le parcours de tel ou tel
rappelez-vous ce qu'on disait de deux
journées
il faut quelqu'un plus à droite est-ce
qu'il faut quelqu'un de plus politique
de plus aguerris au fonctionnement de
l'assemblée c'est la ligne politique
c'est quand même le présent d'un public
qui va inspirer et donc la première
ministre elle est là pour mettre en
oeuvre
une politique que le président la
république voudra avoir mises en oeuvre
donc à partir de là j'en fais pas une
affaire de personnes ont fait une
affaire effectivement de ligne politique
c'est la politique qui doit prendre en
compte le résultat d'hier il faut que le
gouvernement engage sa responsabilité
lors du discours de politique générale
qui va avoir lieu dans quelques jours à
l'assemblée nationale franchement c'est
pas à moi de répondre à ces questions
vous imaginez jeu de je ne sais pas fait
encore j'ai pas mis encore un petit à
l'assemblée nationale et je viendrai
intervenir sur ce sujet donc non j'ai
pas de jeu pas de jets pas de réponse
mais sur la ligne politique ce que vous
en parliez la ligne politique à ce que
désormais elle doit être plus à droite
elle doit elle doit écouter ce qu'ont
dit les français enfin jean qu'elle va
appeler à droite elle doit prendre en
compte le fait que la france ait
effectivement est un pays et qui
majoritairement à droite et à partir de
là il ya sur ce qu'on doit arrêter de
faire des appels du pied du côté de la
gauche il ya sur certaines réformes
économiques sur le le rapport à la
gestion des de la dir de l'état et des
services publics bon bref je vais pas
faire la liste mais il ya un certain
nombre effectivement de politique qui
sans doute doivent être de marqueurs qui
doivent être posées manière à montrer
qu'effectivement on a entendu ce qu'ils
étaient
je le redis sur les rangs sur l'est sur
les retraites sur les réformes
économiques sur la gestion de la dette
et le poids de la dette et la manière
dont effectivement on va se sortir de
cette dette importante voilà ce sont des
sujets et d'ailleurs d'hier c'est un
sujet qu'on a toujours défendu pendant
la campagne et sur lequel edouard
philippe intervient régulièrement vous
êtes nouveau venu à l'assemblée mais a
quand même des questions importantes qui
vont se poser
richard ferrand été battue qui pour
présider l'assemblée demain et puis
christophe castaner a été battue qui
pour prendre la présidence de son groupe
alors je ne serai pas au groupe vous
êtes horizons voilà qui ont présidé
horizon de 10 ans je vais être mis
d'accord pas encore mais on veut tout ça
est quand même assez d'être et toutes
les questions vont se poser à
des réponses urgentes trouveront des
questions urgentes trouveront des
réponses rapides de ça il n'y a pas de
problème mais je vais pas vous dire ce
matin ce qu'il faut comme un homme pour
tel ou tel poste il ya effectivement
sans doute aussi à réorganiser
voilà les postes et les personnes qui
les occupe en fonction aussi de ce qui a
été dit hier en tous les cas moi je suis
très content de voir qu'il ya un groupe
horizon à 28 28 députés on ne sera pas
le plus gros le plus important groupe de
la de l'assemblée nationale mais vu les
normes et composent ce sera un groupe
intéressant parce qu'il ya dans ce
groupe des élus qui ont une expérience
du territoire une expérience de
l'engagement politique au niveau local
ces outils c'était aussi une des
spécificités qui apportait edouard
philippe dans cette danse est dans
paysage politique et dans cette campagne
sans penser campagne présidentielle et
législative donc oui on aura des choses
à dire manière claire mais précisément
de la majorité ça veut dire qu horizons
même si vous n'avez qu'à rendre ces
députés va forcément peser emmanuel
macron va devoir compter avec edouard
philippe et comment edouard philippe va
gérer ce poids comment va-t-il s'en
servir alors invité le il vous répondra
de manière très claire à ces questions
mais en tous les cas edouard philippe a
toujours dit qu'ils seraient
loyal et il le sera et d'autant plus
effectivement dans une période où les
choses sont les élites loyal mais
exigeant oui loyal les maisons mais
gérer exigences effectivement de vouloir
peser sur certaines réformes il a été
très clair depuis début il les a même
cité ces réformes merci
[Musique]